hey what's up my name's samuel leeds
right now i'm feeling a little bit
stressed and i need you to help me out
okay if you're a property investor
you're thinking about getting into
property i need to tell you what the
politicians and the government are
thinking about bringing in to this
country to london which is going to
devastate the housing economy and i'm
literally i'm on my knees and i'm in a
suit i'm in a suit because of how
serious this is they're talking about
bringing in rent control into london
which we know is gonna ripple out across
the country and it's gonna kill
landlords it's gonna really hurt tenants
the people that it's trying to help and
we need to say no listen i'm usually not
want to complain i'm usually one not to
speak up usually i just say whatever's
happening let's just make money and be
an entrepreneur but sometimes there's a
time and a place to stand up and make
change and say no and let me tell you
what's what's happening right now they
are in conversations as i'm speaking
they're in conversations about giving
sadiq khan
power to be able to control
what and what you cannot charge for a
rental property in london we know what's
going to happen if that happens it's
going to rip it across the country and
we've seen it happen all over the world
we've seen it happen in the uk
decades ago and what happened is it
killed the economy so i'm asking you
there's a petition in the link sign the
petition it takes literally 30 seconds
sign the petition it will then send you
an email confirm the email and your vote
counts every person that signs the
petition is the equivalent of a thousand
people saying i agree but most people
just don't take the 30 seconds to sign
the petition sign it and share it and
get as many people as possible to also
sign the petition if you don't know what
rent control is and you haven't got an
opinion on it let me tell you what it is
but while i'm talking just click the
link sign the petition i don't benefit
from you starting the petition
financially this isn't going to help me
financially what it's going to do is
it's going to stand up and say no to
what they're thinking of doing in this
country and even if you're not in london
even if you're living
down south or up north or wherever you
are sign the petition spread it around
rent control what happens is when the
government say in an area
no more rents above a certain point and
start controlling the rents what happens
is landlords developers pull the plug
and stop being able to buy houses to
rent them out that what that does is it
brings up more of a shortage of houses
and rents actually go up
we've seen it happen in new york
homelessness trashed properties empty
properties ghost town areas it is bad
bad news i've even had a debate with
somebody uh an elected labour official
on my youtube channel and talked about
these issues and i'm telling you right
now this is wrong and this cannot happen
okay so if you want to watch the debate
if you want to go and do some research
do it and then sign the petition it's
below we've had about two and a half
thousand people signed the petition so
far we need to hit 10 000 people when we
hit 10 000 and we've got a very limited
time frame to do this if we don't hit 10
000 votes by november they're going to
throw this out okay so we need to get 10
000 votes on this petition by november
which means then the government will
have to respond they'll have to make it
and make a statement on this and their
statement may be
okay we won't bring in rent control and
then suddenly what does that mean it
means that we can relax knowing that
they're not going to mess up our economy
so not only should you sign it spread it
around get your family your friends to
sign it if you know any property
influencers people that are talking
people have got platforms tell them say
oi
spread this petition around you have to
do this not just for investors but also
for tenants because it's bad for
everybody the only person who will win
if this happens is the politicians
that's it
so i've had a whole debate on this i've
done videos about this before but right
now we have a live petition with a
limited time frame please sign it sign
it now take the moment to do that share
it like crazy let's get this up to 10
000 people and let's make sure they
don't ruin
the market for investors and tenants the
same